podrá tu plantease superar ese registro
de 618 y cómo podría afectar o
beneficiar lo que va a ser su
preparación de cara al próximo ciclo
olímpico y yo pues creo que creo que sí
que está en capacidad de hacerlo lo
demostró hace dos años cuando hizo
entorno en polonia el récord mundial y
una semana después lo quebró estamos
hablando del récord mundial bajo techo
lo quebró precisamente en este mismo
evento británico pero en esa oportunidad
se disputaba en glasgow no en birmingham
como ahora lo que termina pasando es que
es apresurado empezar el año de apenas
la primera segunda tercera competencia
buscando un récord del mundo que tardó
tanto tiempo en derribar se porque
recordemos que cuando él lo rompe en
torún el récord tenía seis años vigentes
de vigente desde que lo puso lo vi lenin
y cuando lo rompió la biblia ni tenía 21
años desde la época de sergei bubka este
no es un récord que se mueve mucho y a
esa digamos desde esa perspectiva y
desde esa óptica hay que verlo